en france c'est vrai qu'on tient
beaucoup à la laïcité qui est d'ailleurs
un des principes de base de la
constitution française
cette laïcité elle garantit à la fois la
tolérance et la liberté de conscience
mais il faut dire également qu'elle
s'est imposé relativement récemment et
après de rudes combats qui date d'à
peine un siècle
récit de jean baptiste auprès d'ali une
loi pour séparer les églises et l'état
décembre 1905 la république française
affirme un principe la laïcité
depuis les débuts de la troisième
république une guerre fait rage
elle oppose de france la catholique et
la lake trente années d'affrontement la
laïcité est d'abord un combat
les républicains qui volent d'instaurer
en france une démocratie
surt nécessairement à l'église donc
c'est une épreuve de force dans cette
épreuve de force l'école est un enjeu à
partir de 1880 jules ferry à imposer par
la loi
un enseignement primaire obligatoire et
laïque les congrégations religieuses ont
été exclus de l'enseignement une épreuve
de force mais à l'arrivée un compromis
la laïcité se veut tolérante l'état ne
reconnaît ne salarie ni ne subventionne
aucun culte
mais il garantit l'exercice de ces
cultes et la liberté de conscience
la loi a été on peut dire au départ le
résultat d'un combat d'un combat avec
des excès des excès de part et d'autre
on parle de l'opposition entre les
anticléricaux les cléricaux une loi très
mal acceptée par le parti vaincu ou par
l'église vaincu mais qui finalement va
se révéler une loi de pacification peu à
peu entre l'église catholique et la
république française les relations se
normalise pour la 4e puis la vème
république la laïcité est un principe
constitutionnel
la france est donc une république
indivisible
le laïque démocratique et sociale la
laïcité reste pourtant un enjeu
politique la gauche en a fait un slogan
avant et après 81 la droite défend
l'école privée la querelle scolaire
pouvant corps elle s'embrase
textuellement
1989 autre passion nouveau problème
toujours à l'école trois jeunes élèves
musulmanes d'un collège de creil refuse
d'ôter leur voile pendant leurs cours
elles sont exclues le conseil d'état est
saisi il demande d'apprécier au cas par
cas
ce type d'affaires la limite c'est le
trouble à l'ordre public
mais les affaires de foulards et de
voile se multiplient les partisans de la
laïcité s'en émeuvent les musulmans
comme on dit parce qu'ils sont très
divers on peut pas les les regrouper
sous une même catégorie doivent
simplement faire les mêmes efforts que
ce que firent naguère les catholiques
pour que leur religion soit
effectivement libre de s'affirmer mais
dans le respect des lois de la
république
un millier de cas environ certains très
médiatisée la laïcité redevient un sujet
et public
en décembre dernier le président de la
république annonce solennellement une
loi sur la laïcité
un siècle après la séparation des
églises et de l'état la question laïque
se pose à nouveau mais dans d'autres
termes à la france juste un mot je me
tourne vers frédérique lantieri qui
dirige ici le service société à france 2
alors on entend dire beaucoup de choses
sur le nombre de cas de jeunes filles
voilées dans les écoles
ce qu'on peut savoir finalement écouté
en fait c'est très compliqué à
déterminer parce que comme viennent de
dire le proviseur même une semaine il ya
des situations extrêmement diverses dans
certains établissements on considère
qu'il ya à peu près une ou deux filles
voilées par classe comme par exemple à
mantes la jolie
d'autres y en a pas du tout à villeneuve
d'ascq penser qu'il y en a 58 tout ça
est extrêmement divers en fait l'école
règle la situation au cas par cas il ya
des établissements qui acceptent le
voile d'autres qui ne tolère uniquement
à cause de récréation et en classe et
pas du tout en classe d'autres qu'il
qu'il le refuse absolument
donc tout ça est très varié il ya la
médiatrice de l'éducation nationale qui
s'appelle hanifa cherifi et qui a
longtemps qu'ils travaillent encore à
essayer de résoudre les problèmes
conflictuels
elle note qu'en effet le contentieux
c'est beaucoup a beaucoup diminué mais
parce que justement les questions sont
traitées sol terrain au cas par cas
mais face qui est vraiment noté c'est
qu'en fait le voile induit d'autres
comportements c'est ça en fait le fond
du problème c'est que les filles qui
portent le voile souvent sèche des cours
de gym 9 refuse les cours d'éducation
par exemple de sciences naturelles
conteste des pans entiers de des cours
d'histoire et c'est toute cette cet
amalgame là qui est très compliqué à
gérer et c'est pour ça je crois qu'elle
lors que la loi sur la laïcité
s'imposait alors en quoi la loi
va-t-elle vous aider madame hilson parce
que finalement aujourd'hui des gens tant
que chef d'établissement vous aviez la
possibilité de juger pas fait je
voudrais juste revenir sur le moose
souvent parce que je crois que c'est un
petit peu faux comme à dijon
jean baubérot de dire que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de tout à fait massif mais
ça existe et donc c'est important
alors enjoint la loi en quoi elle va
nous aider on peut la comparer à la loi
evin et l on peut la comparer à la loi
d'orientation sur le problème de
l'absentéisme
ça nous donne un cadre ça nous donne une
issue et si on n'a pas réussi vraiment à
persuader les élèves si on n'a pas
réussi à faire le chemin avec eux au
bout du compte c'est vrai qu'il y à la
sanction
ça nous donne cette possibilité mais
encore une fois c'est une possibilité
que nous espérons ne jamais avoir à
utiliser mais c'est ça qu'elle nous
apporte alors très bien
juste courte réponse je me tourne vers
les représentants des religions
monsieur le rabbin enfin je vous posais
à tous les trois la même question si
vous pouviez répondre très brièvement
lorsqu'il ya un conflit dans la sphère
publique entre la loi de la république
et la loi divine laquelle doit-on
appliquée monsieur le rabbin
d'imposition juive est clair sur la
question la loi de l'état l'emportent
sur la loi religieuse en la matière
l'enseigneur deux fois le problème est
de savoir de quelle des lois il s'agit
on peut pas répondre comme ça aussi
brutalement
je pense que si ces scènes ne suis pas
jésus ici je suis pas juge et simplement
d intelligent c'est à dire que c'est pas
la même chose qu'on prend 6 et 6 élus
oui c'est ça c'est cissé s'il s'agit par
exemple d'un problème de vêtements aussi
s'agit d'après mme fondamentale en poils
de vêtements et sur un point non
monsieur un problème fondamental c'est
le programme de vêtements ce ne mérite
pas je crois une querelle
ce que je crains c'est que justement
face une fausse querelle et qu'on en
arrive justement à une sorte de guerre
des religions à travers ça ah ça c'est
ma crainte
monsieur louis bujan mais je me suis à
la loi vous l'observez enfin vous
demanderez qu'on observe moi jamais je
me suis posé je pense qu'il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas à un musulman qui se dit est
ce que est ce que j'ai à choisir entre
la loi de la république et la loi
religieuse
je pense que c'est la loi de la
république qui est notre loi mais je
suis convaincu que la loi de la
république doit être une loi qui
respecte il y eu d'accord des
consciences individuelles aventure je
vous demandais de padt jésus
si la loi est votée on l'appliquerait
bourse engrais d'appliquer non mais ce
n'est pas une question à poser la
question non non je m'excuse monsieur
stasi je pense que je pense pas qu'on
pose un citoyen ce que vous voulez est
ce que vous allez appliquer la loi ou
non à six parce que si j'applique pas la
loi moi je la régence alors je vais
avoir la réponse de tout citoyen il est
inné bien sûr s'il ya une loi et l'état
respecté mais est-ce qu'on peut
m'interdire de contester la loi
lorsqu'il est en cours d'élaboration
non c'est une fois qu'elle sera notre
non je parle et n'est pas encore voté à
melle va être votée discuter alors
qu'elle sera votée
bon je m'excuse il discutait d'accord
non moi moi de quoi j'ai l'inquiétude
que j'ai et de beaucoup de musulmans de
france
c'est que maintenant le fait de dire que
je conteste le projet de loi c'est que
je suis devenu moins citoyens que les
autres mais c'est le problème
mais certains ont le droit de dire non
pas vrai mais c'est vous même et vous
l'avez manifs et mais c'est pas tout le
monde y est tout bête mais c'est pas lui
qui le dit pas dire ça alors c'est qui
se dit actuellement c'est sa musique
sans transition de manifester dans la
rue quand ils ne sont pas contents c'est
déjà beaucoup de jeunes musulmans vous
peut pas le faire c'est bien même les
musulmans c'est bien ce que ses rivaux
mais prenons ici
félicitations s'il vous plaît on n'est
pas ici dans un meeting
alors nous allons passer maintenant à la
deuxième étape femmes de france parce
que effectivement c'est souvent la
question la place de la femme dans la
société qui se posent quand on évoque
l'islam et je rappelle une phrase que
prononcer le président d'un public
jacques chirac quand il a prononcé son
discours le 17 décembre dernier le degré
de civilisation d'une société se mesure
d'abord à la place qu'ils occupent les
femmes et bernard stasi tout à l'heure
vous parliez de témoignages qui ont
amené la commission à changer d'avis
d'après ce que vous m'avez dit ce sont
beaucoup de témoignages de jeunes femmes
qui vous ont littéralement bouleversé
d'ailleurs oui je tiens à dire tout
d'abord que je respecte les femmes
musulmanes qui de leur plein gré portent
le voile et j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire a dû faire entreprises jeu malgré
ce en plusieurs femmes musulmanes ne si
vous portez le voile volontairement
c'est votre affaire
enfin je vous respecte mais je plains
scène elles sont nombreuses qui le
portent parce qu'ils sont obligés de le
faire
c'est ça qu'il faut prendre en compte
d'ailleurs que les témoignages qui nous
ont le plus bouleversé ces des
témoignages de femmes musulmanes de
turcs en particulier qui ont été obligés
pendant de très nombreuses années de
porter le voile sous la pression brutal
mais peuvent-ils brutal jeudi brutale de
leur père ou de leur grand frère et qui
se sent libéré qui ont rompu avec la
famille tout en restant des angles
ullmann ce sont elles qui nous ont dit
enfin prenez conscience de la gravité du
problème
prenez penser à toutes ces femmes qui
sont obligées de porter le voile qui
sont humiliés qui se sentent humiliés
alors justement je récitais le le
témoignage de quelqu'un que vous avez
entendu je crois qu'ils aient chahdortt
djavann qui est une auteure iranienne et
qui a écrit un livre qui s'appelle bas
les voiles et qui dit j'avais 13 ans
quand la loi islamique que s'est imposée
en iran
sous la férule de khomeiny et elle
ajoute rentré de france avec la
bénédiction de beaucoup d'intellectuels
français jean baubérot les interviews
français sont aveugles
non les intellectuels français essaye de
réfléchir d'analyser
bon alors ce qui s'est passé en 1910 à
178 c'est malheureusement qu'il y avait
une affreuse dictature en iran qui était
celle du chat etc a d'abord été ça le
problème
effectivement bon alors malheureusement
comme souvent on a remplacé une
dictature par une autre la libération
s'est mis en dictature et c'est pourquoi
l'émancipation dois admettre le
pluralisme est actuellement il ya des
femmes musulmanes qui s'émancipe en
refusant de porter le voile
mais je regrette ça peut apparaître
paradoxal à certains il y en a d'autres
qui s'émancipe en le portant
il faut prendre acte de ce fait
elisabeth badinter vous êtes pour la loi
vous je vous pose la même question est
ce que les intellectuels français sont
aveugles parfois je suis pour la loi et
je pense que les intellectuels français
ou autres peuvent être aveugle et j'ai
souvenir de voyage en avion de plusieurs
intellectuels français pour soutenir le
régime de khomeiny
donc on peut se tromper je pense qu' il
est temps aujourd'hui de plus tromper
alors je vous propose de regarder un
reportage mené par nathalie sapina et
virginie travers en fait elles ont
enquêté parce qu'elles ont été intrigués
de voir et de lire que le conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins
recommandaient à ses membres de ne plus
donner aux jeunes filles musulmanes qui
veulent est le leur demander d
certificat de virginité alors pourquoi
reportage officiellement il n'est pas
réclamée par les mosquées mais dans les
faits le certificat de virginité reste
une pratique vivace
officiellement les médecins français ne
doivent pas rédiger un tel document le
conseil de l'ordre vient de le rappeler
mais dans le secret des cabinets
médicaux
la détresse des jeunes femmes oblige
parfois à certains arrangements
si on veut pas voir ce conflit avec les
parents on peut toujours signer un
papier qui de façon n'a aucune valeur
mais c'est une façon quand même de
garder contact dont je veux dire en
terre en théorie je suis d'accord il
faut pas les faire certificat en
pratique je pense que c'est un peu plus
difficile comme ça de laisser partir ses
ces petites jeunes qu'ils soient amenés
par leurs parents sait pas trop quelle
va être leur avenir après le plus
souvent le certificat de virginité est
demandée par la famille ou la belle
famille pour préparer un mariage
parfois il sert simplement à rassurer
les parents j'avais une amie qui après
avoir fait un voyage à l'étranger avec
l'école ses parents lui avaient dit ok
en classe partir mais quand survient on
fera t-on certificat la lutte contre le
certificat de virginité
c'est le cheval de bataille de ces
jeunes militantes qui ont fondé une
association à montpellier pour défendre
les droits de la femme musulmane que le
conjoint ou le veuille ou pas ce sera
pareil je refuserais 1,6 sa famille fait
pression ben moi je ferais pression de
mon côté et le gall le paradoxe même si
elles sont opposés aux certificats
question pudeur elle revendique la
virginité jusqu'au mariage
être contre le certificat de virginité
ça veut pas dire être contre la chasteté
bien au contraire nous on est pour la
chasteté mais ne pas dévoiler à tout le
monde que cette personne est viré bien
souvent les jeunes maghrébines se
retrouve coincé entre des traditions
archaïques et les moeurs d'une société
libérée d'où une recrudescence de
certaines pratiques sexuelles qui
inquiète les médecins
il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui ont les
pratiques qu'elles n'auraient peut-être
pas souhaité d'ailleurs au départ des
pratiques de ce dôme idée pratique de
fellation pour faire plaisir aux
partenaires qui permet de garder la
virginité et qui a quand même des
conséquences
à la fois je dirais un physique et
psychologique car souvent ce sont des
rapports sans protection donc un grand
risque d'infections sexuellement
transmissibles et pour toutes celles qui
ont franchi l'interdît et qui veulent
pourtant sauvé les apparences une ultime
solution la reconstruction de l'hymen
une opération chirurgicale pratiquée
sous anesthésie
les gynécologues sont les
reconstructions du maine sais c'est pas
quelque chose d'exceptionnel pour
certains refusent bien sûr moi
personnellement je les accepte de les
refaire des devez faire c'est pas simple
ça me pose comme des problèmes un petit
peu j'ai des opinions contradictoires un
petit peu là dessus il ya cette
sacralisation de la virginité moi qui me
gêne beaucoup puisque c'est quand même
manifestation de la domination masculine
sous couvert souvent de principes
religieux etc
mais c'est quand même la domination
masculine en faisant les réfections
demand je rentre un petit peu dans le
système qui est quelque chose que je
combats totalement un système où la
femme est considérée comme une
marchandise qui prend toute sa valeur
avec un certificat de garantie alors
frédérique lantieri il y à des enquêtes
qui ont été menées ce qu'on arrive à
savoir à peu près ce qui se passe c'est
quelle est l'importance de ce phénomène
on en parlera après savoir si ça
correspond à quelque chose de prescrits
par l'islam ou pas mais est ce qu on a
connaissance de l'importance de ce
phénomène
je vais d'abord rappelé que c'est un
fait divers particulièrement atroces qui
a un peu a révélé la dégradation des
conditions des femmes dans les banlieues
c'est la jeune sohane qui le 4 octobre
2002 et retrouvée brûlée vive dans un
local de poubelles à vitry sur seine
alors en fait depuis différentes études
confirment un peu la détresse des femmes
issues de l'immigration notamment par
exemple la question des mariages forcés
qui était totalement inconnu jusqu en
à cette époque à cette date là il ya des
instances sociales qui raconte que des
jeunes lycéennes viennent se plaindre
que tous les week-ends elles sont
enfermés dans la chambre de leur parent
avec un homme qu'on leur présente comme
leur mari et qu'il est leur imposer des
relations sexuelles
en fait aujourd'hui le le conseil le
haut conseil à l'intégration estime
grosso modo à 70 milles les femmes
issues
les jeunes filles issues de familles
maghrébines turques ou africaines qui
sont soumises aux mariages forcés
70000 quand même en face andy mise quand
même et un dernier chiffre pour conclure
en gros enfin non pas en gros on sait
qu'une femme les femmes issues de
l'immigration sont deux fois plus
nombreuses que les françaises à subir
des agressions sexuelles alors nadia
mairie vous êtes infirmières et
sociologue et je vous ai vu réagir à ce
reportage parce que je sais vous même
vous avez vécu cette expérience du
certificat de virginité
j'ai surtout été le témoin dans ma vie
professionnelle et ma vie militante de
la parole et des souffrances des sans
voix et descend voile il faudra quand
même à un moment laissé l'espace à
celles qui sont dans l'oppression la
domination
je suis très heureuse d'avoir vu cette
ce reportage puisque j'allais moi même
évoqué la sodomie les coups et blessures
sur les jeunes femmes
la virginité qui est imposé moi j'ai vu
dans des quartiers de strasbourg des
jeunes filles qu'on vendait comme des
bas comme des bêtes dans des marchés à
bestiaux où chacune avait un prix de
manière à ce que quelqu'un dans le pays
d'origine
puisse venir en france et se marier avec
elle combien ont été violées combien ont
subi des oppressions par mariage forcé
dans le pays d'origine et j'ai même
rencontré une jeune fille qu'on avait ne
relaie prisés c'est à dire qu'on lui
avait donné des neuroleptiques pour
qu'elles acceptent d'aller jusqu'à
l'aéroport
et ça avait été le vécu déjà de sa
grande soeur madonna mairie je mets pas
en doute ce que vous dites mais monsieur
etats-unis tombées vous avez été
ministre
vous avez été membre de gouvernement
vous a été très longtemps un homme
politique c'est possible ça en france et
là je le crains oui hélas vraiment hélas
mais comment on peut pas l'empêcher
il faut l'empêcher alors je me tourne
vers saïda cada vous êtes voilée on le
constate et vous avez écrit un livre
d'ailleurs l'une voilée et et l'autre
pas quand vous entendez tout ça vous dit
c'est pas vrai c'est sur des histoires
sont des fantasmes
ce qui est intéressant fait dans ce
qu'on vient d'entendre c'est le
rapprochement qu'on fait quand on part
de la question des banlieues avec la
question sur le lit
la laïcité quand on aborde la question
des banlieues on parle sous l'angle de
de ce qui se passe à l'intérieur comme
si c'était tout ce qui se passait on a
parlé des tournantes comme étant un
terme propre au quartier comme si ça se
passait que dans les quartiers ce qui a
dénoncé dénonçons le les mariages forcés
ne sont pas le fait de l'islam le fait
de toutes les églises et des sévices
corporels que peuvent subir les femmes
autant physiques que psychologiques ne
sont pas le fait de l'islam la tue en
tant que musulmane en est claire il n'y
a pas de prescription là dessus ce qui
est intéressant de relever
moi j'ai noté quand madame babès parlais
tout à l'heure et c'est un lien que je
peux faire
quand elle donner son point de vue à
savoir que le foulard puisque c'est
comme en inde et des thèmes de ce débat
ce soir n'est pas une prescription
religieuse
c'est son point de vue c'est le point de
vue partagé par certains nombre de
personnes avec elle et il ya un autre
point de vue celle d'autres musulmans
qu'ils disent est une prescription
religieuse qui le vivent en toute
liberté
preuve à madame babès de me démontrer
que le contraire pour ça qu'ils ont
choisi de le porter la question qui se
pose c'est pourquoi la république a
choisi un camp et pas un autre
comment se fait-il que la république a
choisi les musulmans qui ont dit le
foulard n'est pas une prescription
religieuse et à dénigrer ce qu'ils
disent est une prescription religieuse
le critère est quand même intéressant il
faut relever aujourd'hui que moi en tant
que musulmane je vis l'exercice de ma
foi on me demande aujourd'hui de choisir
entre ce choix là et ma vie or on veut
l'interdire à l'école oui non pas que
moi qui suis concerné look ce que je
veux dire c'est que aujourd'hui on est
dans une situation un peu paradoxale on
reconnaît la responsabilité pénale de
l'enfant l'âge de 12 ans c'est à dire
qu'on admet qu'un enfant est
suffisamment grand responsable pour être
sanctionnée en fonction de ses actes par
contre pour les choix qu'il est en
mesure de faire et limite sous tutelle
de l'état et plus quand il s'agit des
questions relatives aux cartes yb
il est simplement terminer là dessus ce
qui a des noms sont à dénoncer dénonçons
le haut niveau des quartiers et que nous
avons entendu là ça ressemble à quelque
chose qui vous paraît le vrai ou pas et
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai cette réalité
il existe bien avant 1996 et beaucoup
l'ont dénoncé bien avant beaucoup
d'associations travail sur le terrain le
mib diversité les motiver à toulouse
dont on n'entend pas souvent la parole
mais ce qui est intéressant de voix
c'est con mais c'est finalement de
légitimer la position qu'on a sur la
question du foulard par rapport à des
situations dont finalement on n'est pas
responsable ni de près ni de loin
or aujourd'hui on dit au nom de celles
qui souffrent interdisons à celles qui
ont décidé de le porter le foulard
oui moi je voudrais rajouter que en plus
de celles qui souffrent et que
évidemment une catégorie professionnelle
tels que les professionnels dans les
hôpitaux on a traité
moi je voudrais aussi évoqué le contrôle
social
parce que finalement on dit on va parler
des trains qui arrivent à l'heure où des
trains qui n'arrivent pas à l'heure et
bien les trains qui arrivent à l'heure
ce sont aujourd'hui les jeunes filles
voilées
parce qu'elles sont dans un continuum à
partir d'une éducation à partir d'une
perception de la du culte qui est
logique
celles qui n'arrivent pas à l'heure et
qui sont aujourd'hui des femmes
émancipées qui ont des diplômes qu'on
appelle l'élite et heureusement je m'en
réjouis
de plus en plus ce sont des personnes et
particulièrement des femmes qui ont et à
ceux qui ont eu à se battre de manière
inimaginable je veux revenir dans les
années 80 quand j'étais adolescente
où étaient les structures les
assistantes sociales ou sont aujourd'hui
les possibilités de prise en charge de
ce jeune femme quand elle refuse mme un
dogme qui est un dogme religieux est une
autre chose
leïla babès a fait une explication une
interprétation une explication de ces
interprétations possibles
moi je voudrais dire que peu m'importe
qui a écrit dans le coran
peu m'importe ce que disent les livres
sur la situation de la femme
je vis en 2004 et je souhaite qu'à
travers la planète
les femmes en tout cas en france si on
montre vous avez la france la république
impose que notre appartenance cultuelle
ne soit pas alors visibles justement
fouad alaoui un mot quand même là dessus
est ce que le coran peut être adapté
pour suivre l'évolution de la société ou
bien est-ce qu'il est gravé dans le
marbre pour l'éternité la question il me
plaît dans le sens où
parce que parce qu'il rentre dans ma
logique à savoir que je refusais
annexion littéraliste du texte sacré moi
je suis le courant que je représente
nous sommes dans une démarche où nous
voulons avoir une lecture du texte sacré
qui permet une quête contextualisations
de cette lecture et de la pratique
religieuse pour être en conformité avec
ma réalité
mais pour ceux ci je veux quand même pas
refondre les fondements de la religion
et je suis convaincu que les fans de
monde de ma religion ne sont pas
contraires aux valeurs républicaines
c'est ça c'est votre avec dans le coran
il ya des choses qui aujourd'hui ne
devrait pas être appliqué oui à écouter
alors s'il fallait appliquer s'il
fallait respecter le voile parce qu'ils
seraient une prescription coranique
alors il faut flageller les adultères il
faut couper les mains des voleurs il
faut appliquer les lois sur l'héritage
autorisé la polygamie etc etc
il y a des choses qui n'ont même pas ça
mais lors des plus proches compagnons du
prophète
le deuxième calife omar a décidé de ne
pas appliquer le coran en sanctionnant
les voleurs donc on ne coupons pas les
mains parce que c'était une mesure
inhumaine
alors qu'on se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui on
dise que le voile est un fondement de la
religion ce n'est pas vrai disons
simplement faisons une lecture
raisonnable sans c est comment dirais-je
simplement oui contextualise je vous
l'avais dit du coran à propos du voile
et dire que ce n'est pas une pratique
religieuse que ce n'est pas une
prescription religieuse que c'est une
coutume ancestrale patriarcale que le
coran à d'une façon ou d'une autre
entérinée mais qui aujourd'hui n'a plus
de raison dans sa vie la cada juste un
mot parce que j'aurai qu'on entend
votre ami qui se trouve derrière vous et
moi ce que je voulais dire c'est que ce
que dit tout à l'heure on peut condamner
ce qu'on veut condamner on peut
condamner tout ce qui a à faire mais le
problème aujourd'hui s'il ya des femmes
qui portent le foulard qui vivent dans
la société moi personnellement j'ai même
créé ma société
donc on est dans une danse dans un
registre très intéressant pour la
liaison leu leu leu l'avenir même de la
société de tous ceux qui sont dans ces
sociétés là moi ce que je déplore c'est
que pour justement justifier ce débat
d'interdiction sur le foulard on met en
avant des situations que tout le monde
condamne et d'ailleurs c'est simplement
pour finir parce que ça me semble
intéressant la plupart des jeunes filles
qui sont dans les quartiers sont dans un
dans un processus qui est pichichi
relais si vous voulez fâchent tout que
c'est exceptionnel ce qu'elles font dans
les quartiers y en a qui sont
aujourd'hui qu'elle cautionne qu'elle ne
condamne pas qu'elles sont dans une
logique finalement de choisir entre pour
le foulard contre le foulard comme si le
foulard finalement était à l'origine de
tous les maux existantes dans les
quartiers ce que ce qu'a rappelé
monsieur baubérot tout à l'heure ce qui
était intéressant c'est que
effectivement on doit répondre
séparés par an pour maux sociaux de
pouvoir ensuite régler ce qui a mal on
entendre qu'on entende pardon sarah
talbi qui se trouve derrière vous reste
un cas un peu particulier parce que vous
étiez catholique je crois de naissance
et de vous êtes converti à l'islam mais
alors après un cheminement personnel je
me suis converti à l'islam est en fait
ce que je voudrais faire assister en
fait c'est que donc moi je suis
française française les gaulois souvent
comme on les appelle donc comme quoi ce
n'est pas qu'une religion des immigrés
donc premièrement et surtout en fait
le fait que je porte le voile c'est
vraiment un acte de foi et c'est un
choix de ma conscience personnelle donc
qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à vous
convertir ses recherches
et recherché alors convictions
personnelles quoi la jeune c'est quand
même une chose qui nous a trié kim hoa
mattrick quand même c'est que bien
souvent il ya comme ça des définitions
qui sont données qui sont plutôt
généreuse mais est-ce que lorsque vous
regardez les journaux les journaux
télévisés ou bien peut-être envoyé
spécial jeudi soir dernier je sais pas
si vous avez eu l'occasion de regarder
il y avait des scènes de tortures en
iran est ce que vous n'avez pas
constater quand même que partout où
s'applique la loi musulmane
les femmes ne sont pas considérés comme
étant les égales des hommes dans la
société
c'est pas vrai revenons à la source ne
regardons pas un pur cités ont dit des
pays musulmans mais c'est pas la loi
telle que l'islam n'est pas appliquée
donc moi je reviens à la source et je
dis tout le temps ne jugeons pas les
musulmans pour juger l'islam jugeons à
l'islam la femme n'est pas inférieure à
l'homme en islam non c'est faux donc je
ne me sens pas du tout inférieur et pas
du tout elisabeth badinter et régions
écoutez en ce qui me concerne je bénis
le ciel que nous soyons dans une
république laïque et je bénis le ciel
également que cette école laïque
existent pour protéger toutes ces
petites jeunes filles actuellement qui
sont sous la pression des familles des
grands frères des religieux du quartier
même et je veux même dire d autre petit
jeune fille qui viennent voilée à
l'école et qui leur font la leçon je
pense que les dés sont pipés ici comme
ils le sont toujours
parce qu'en vérité nous ne les entendre
on jamais ces petites jeunes filles
peut-être dans la commission de monsieur
stasi en tête à tête et en privé elles
ont pu parler alors si il y à une
catégorie de jeunes femmes de jeunes
filles de prix adolescente à protéger et
que la république se doit de protéger ce
sont elles les mettent les silencieuses
les sans défense je voudrais dire aussi
parce que ça me tient à coeur c'est que
tout tous les progrès qui ont été faits
pour que la femme devienne maître de son
corps
tous ces progrès pardonnez moi de vous
le dire ont été faits contre les
religieux tous quel qu'il soit quels
qu'ils soient je voudrais simplement ce
détail penser que l'accouchement sans
douleur dans les années 50 a été
condamnée avec férocité par le pape de
l'époque qui était pie xii et je
pourrais vous donner
je pourrais vous donner de l'église
d'angleterre l'a fait un siècle
je souhaiterais vous donner tous les
autres exemples qui sont qui ont scandé
la libération des femmes et moi ce que
je souhaite c'est qu'on a on enseigne à
toutes les petites françaises de toutes
origines qu'elles ont le droit de ne pas
être vierge que le record est à elle
qu'il n'appartient ni au père ni au mari
ni à personne et c'est cet enseignement
de la maîtrise de soi de la liberté qui
exactement la caractéristique d'une
démocratie avancée
alors quand je vois pardonnez moi de
vous le dire des dames voit les adultes
c'est leur droit
c'est tout à fait indiscutable mais
quand elle pense qu'elle incarne la
libération des femmes
ça veut dire qu'elle refuse de voir que
l'essentiel des femmes musulmanes
aujourd'hui c'est à dire des millions de
femmes vivent sous la pression du voile
et qu'elle le veuille ou non ces images
qui nous viennent tous les jours
d'irak d'iran pour une pas citer tous
les autres pays musulmans
ces images là sont celles de
l'oppression des femmes et je ne
souhaite pas que les petites françaises
en subissent ce qu'on peut
[Musique]